as we all know schools are out in most
parts of the United States right now and
we don't know when schools are coming
back and so many youngsters
coast-to-coast
depend on schools to get the lunches and
the nutrition that they need and right
now you can visit dot milk dot-com to
find a listing of participating meal to
go service sites locating locations
around your neighborhoods where families
can pick up meals because no kid should
have to go hungry as we all know so go
to healthy eating dot org slash school
meals again healthy eating dot org slash
school meals or go visit dot milcom to
see if there's any help that can be
gotten for you and your family and your
kid and here on behalf of the California
milk processing board and also on behalf
of the Dairy Council of California is
the 27th overall pick of the 2017
National Basketball Association Draft
from your Los Angeles Lakers Cal Kuzma
how are you Kyle I'm good are you doing
I am I am better for talking to you how
what's I am I am my wife Suzie who you
know because of her covering the Lakers
she's well she wanted to hello and she
wanted me to send you her best as well I
do have to start this interview because
I have in this manner and it may sound
weird but I did see her Instagram are
you in the are you in the tub right now
talking to me because I saw your
Instagram post the other day Kyle where
are you I'm acting that in the tub
talking to you right now
okay that's good yeah just sitting here
okay look dion sanders is called in from
his tub right that's happened before
correct Chris that's happened before on
this show Deion Sanders not just anybody
had the one and only well I mean you
know Kyle I mean it's all it's all good
okay but see they look mad are you
healthy is your family everybody that
you know is everybody fine in your in
your world calm
everyone is good about role families
good friends are good organizations good
so that's great yeah you know that's
that's the the shining shining light
okay walk me through when you first
heard you know about Rudy Gobert and and
what that was meaning for potentially
your season or NBA season Kyle when did
you first learn about all that um I
think we were home at the time we were
home during this and I was at home
watching the game you know watching the
game about starting it's kind of just
folded and being you know how kind of
went but you know it wasn't necessarily
a surprise you know income of buyers
global buyers at that you know has the
firepower to you know hit anyone you
know and it just kind of just shows you
and puts things in perspective that you
know any and everybody get it so did you
guys get tested right away yes okay and
and everything was fine with you
personally from yes okay yeah all right
knocking on knocking on wood right there
what have you been told about the return
of the NBA what do you know right now
Kyle obviously it's it's up in the air
it's fluid to say the least
but what have you what have you been
told um just as much as you pretty much
you know nobody really knows you know
this is such a weird and crazy time for
us right now just because you know quite
frankly we just haven't as a society
when you've gone through something like
this within the lee-char our generation
so you know it's just a waiting game
it's all about taking your precautions
measures being safe and making sure that
you know everyone is safe and just doing
their part standing inside and you know
really just you know trying to help the
world out by doing that of course and
then you know if it is decided that the
world can is ready and can handle
potentially playing in front of an NBA
playing in front of no
but it would require folks like yourself
I mean we all talk about hey what can
happen when for the sport to come back
dr. Falchi of the NIH even said on a
snapchat interview that it is possible
for sports to come back but everybody's
got to be sequestered everybody's got to
stay in a hotel that's the only thing
they can do is basically go from the
hotel to the arena or hotel to the
stadium everybody that either drives a
bus or serves food or does anything
associated with the return of the sport
has to do the same thing and and we're
all as fans go sure but you're the one
who's got to do it would you be up for
something like that Carl yeah you know
that's you know that's the thing that's
the interesting thing with you know kind
of do that dynamic you know for that
dynamic but you said you know we would
have to be you know in a hotel could
never leave family members even if
they're allowed in they're not how does
that go and then you have to think about
the workers so you know let's say we're
in Vegas and you know we're staying at a
certain hotel all the people that work
today also have to stay there too so you
know yeah that's that's that's a pretty
happy thing and I think the one thing
obviously sure as a competitor and
someone that loves to give basketball of
course you know we all want to play
notice what we do for our livelihood and
this is some that we've been doing for
our entire life but I think the thing
that's kind of being missed with you
know people saying yeah we want you guys
attention plays you know there's a lot
of players out there that have the same
worries that the the actual the regular
human regular person as you know you
know playing against people is a safe or
whatever whatnot so you know I think
that um know it's such a iffy thing
right now and very unsure certainty that
said how often are you and the rest of
the Lakers maybe either getting together
by teleconference zoom however you want
to call it do you guys stay in touch or
or
you working out I mean how do you stay
potentially ready if things do hopefully
make a great turn for us as an entire
populace if not world that allows the
possibility of this to happen well you
know we're uh you know as you guys kind
of seen throughout the season you know
we're pretty tight in the group novi we
always talk to each other every day you
know we have the group chat we always
communicate within there and you know I
think the biggest thing from athletic
standpoint you know we can't really play
basketball there's no access to gyms and
things of that nature you know
absolutely we can't get in our own team
facilities and you know most facilities
are shut down too because of this is of
the seriousness of it so the biggest
thing is what you can control is take
care of your body you know still as a
you know athlete you know prepared for
if the season does come back you have to
be ready you know so that challenges
involve just even well and you know
still working out as you can you know a
lot of guys are probably working out at
home you know for me I have a given my
house so I could work out and it's fun
so I'm looking blessed had that but you
know just tried to find out what you see
what you can do you know
Kyle Kuzma of the Los Angeles Lakers
here also part of the Dairy Council of
California and the folks at got milk
with the California processing board to
make sure kids get get meals because you
know so many kids that look up to you
and follow you this is so important I'm
glad that you're doing and how did you
get involved in all this Kyle to make
sure that kids that normally maybe get
their nutrition through schools can
somehow get fed and get the nutrition
the milk the proteins that they require
the calcium they require for me I just
think that athletes should always use
their you know their platform for good
and for good measures and for me I just
wanted to be a little bit vocal during
this time you know just you know let
people have that awareness you know
there's a lot of families out there
especially in the state of California
that
no struggling right now during these
crazy times and may not have food for
their kids or you know poop for you know
multiple kids in house so you know
partner with God milk and you know they
just are doing a great job for really
just putting the message out of free
school meals are still available
suggesting sites out here so so again
milk milk calm and healthy eating org
slash school meals to check on all that
now
Kyle how does a kid from Flint Michigan
wind up in Utah to go to school how did
that happen how does a kid from Flint
Michigan wind up in Utah to go to school
and start a career in basketball how did
you wind up there I you know I had a I
had a really short I had like a short
recruiting like list of schools that I
had I really kind of liked and I wanted
to get out of the state of Michigan it's
just kind of like you know explore you
know especially would be a plant so you
know Coach K and crystal yack that is
you know no cons won me over got sick my
physics you tall and I love it out there
you know it's amazing you know I always
tried to find time and summer times go
back there and you know it's a great
state so coach beeline Michigan my alma
mater didn't come knocking on your door
car they did not they not I know I know
that's your alma mater to I know you're
a big gold blue guy I am but they were
not knocking at all not is though not as
always as you know I'd the flintstones
back in the day I mean he never told
either not at all I had I had like
Central Michigan Detroit Mercy Oakland I
like those kinds of Michigan schools all
right how about all that I mean a crazy
it all it all works out never where he
starts its course of course and when did
when did you learn on draft night that
that Nets at that you were wearing was
insignificant you were going to the
Lakers when did that happen I knew for a
minute because I knew that the Lakers
had the 27th pick
you kind of know you know who they know
they trade the pigs so yeah I'm new I'm
Kennelly okay and then you show up my
gosh you show up in LA and I mean man
what a heck of a year it's been yeah I
know and then just just so much you know
as we've been talking about coronavirus
and everything going on Kobe's passing I
still can't believe I can't believe that
what was he what was your relationship
with him how did he how did he bring you
along and the whole Mamba mentality
potentially shown to you if not placed
within you calm well you know that kind
of came about my curiosity about the
game and you know just about life
growing up he's the idol of mine one of
my favorite players and you know getting
drafted LA you know kind of put me in
the driver's seat to you know try to get
it trying to build that relationship and
I you know I kind of hounded properly to
pestered him you know trying to get in
contact with Toby Serena and highly did
one night we had dinner and you know
ever since that day no any time I needed
something you know advice to go work out
just called him about off the core
things business basketball it was always
there you know some of that really
jiggly you know care care to cared about
me and you know I kind of saw that in
school well you mentioned pálinka
obviously he's the the top basketball
executive with the Lakers and was a
longtime agent and obviously the
Godfather to Kobe's children and I do
believe vice versa do you think um the
fact that in this whole changing over
the roster that you were the guy that
the Lakers held on to do you think Kobe
had anything to do with that
Kyle um I don't know I don't know I
think I think that Rob you know
obviously being around Toby for you know
many many years you know pretty much
this whole entire career with his agent
being around them you know obviously
they you know respect each other's
basketball knowledge ease and opinion so
it could have been a thing but I don't
know no no because I I just was
wondering that because again when we
interviewed Kobe a couple of summers ago
he mentioned he was training you he
mentioned you know he mentioned you
specifically he didn't talk about too
many other people but he mentioned you
yeah yeah no for sure I was my god and
now you're playing with LeBron I mean oh
what a what a life and I hope for you
you and everybody else that you get back
to go back out there again Kyle real
real soon before I let you go is there's
everybody you know I'm having my wife
and I are having like virtual drinks
with friends like virtual dinner parties
and things like that or is there a
virtual Taco Tuesday that's going on
that we don't know about right now
school space time okay a lot of
cocktails you know same happy message
you're doing right now but LeBron is not
like his hey hey here's the ears the
address everybody zoom in for a Taco
Tuesday he has not done that yet no
nothing good ideas oh babe please maybe
I should bring that up your group chat
actually sounds like a very good idea my
gosh
I like making people's lives better just
by having them appear in the Rich Eisen
show but I know maybe I need to do this
I think that this is for sure let's do
that let's do that a virtual Taco
Tuesday and then when you you know
Instagram it out or some just go at Rich
Eisen show that's all I ask
okay and then you know I eat tacos too
on Tuesdays just in case you know you
would just hand it out that that link
okay that's funny that means I'm serious
no no but you laughed and then said for
sure I mean you know I'm very sensitive
I'm very sad all right Kyle thanks for
the call let's do this again more often
and and again thanks for coming on dot
milcom healthy eating dot org slash
school meals to find out again a listing
of participating meal to go service
sites locations and potentially in your
neighborhood to get some food on the
table for kids thanks for the call Kyle
yes sir
right thank you fax Kyle Kuzma hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch
right here